I really didn't have a good reason to
join Greek life I kind of just stumbled
into it I had a lot of trouble making
friends my first few months of school
growing up I did a lot of theater and I
didn't really have a lot of guy friends
I didn't come out until my junior year
actually so I've been out for a really
long time I actually wasn't even out
until after I graduated college in
college I wasn't sure I had feelings but
thought maybe it was phase yeah I was
hesitant about rushing uh because you
know there's a stereotype of
fraternities being you know hyper
masculine hyper straight organizations
and you know as a freshman in college I
wanted to just sort of explore what it
meant to be gay was I worried that you
know my sexual orientation would
prohibit me from joining or would hinder
the process yes first day that I rushed
I went to a fraternity and one of the
questions they asked me was if you could
have sex with any male cartoon character
who would it be and I was just like
really is that like what you're trying
to get to know about me at a certain
point I told like my pledge educator
that I was gay he was like oh yeah we
know I was like does everyone know and
they're like yeah we know and we don't
care I had built a strong foundation
with my pledge brothers and so to tell
them that I was gay was just sharing
them again a little bit more about who I
was what I thought was most surprising
they were incredibly curious about what
it was to be gay
spoiler alert nothing changed the
conversation was super easy and they
were really really accepting but I was
definitely I definitely have
reservations that they would feel weird
that all of a sudden now that I'm gay
that I'm going to try and hook up with
every single one of them which is such a
ridiculous fear that gets put in your
head this guy wanted to bring his
boyfriend to weekend way formal and some
people like were uncomfortable with that
that kind of just rubbed me the wrong
way because it was encouraged for these
guys to like find a random girl by the
time I graduated it was like a guy a
couple guys that would bring their
boyfriends to formals and stuff and that
was like cool to see because it didn't
have to be a big deal anymore
when I joined my fraternity I didn't
know that
there were other LGBT brothers but after
I became a full-fledged brother
I was connected with gay and bisexual
and queer brothers from other chapters
and we you know we stay connected via
social media outlets being around a
bunch of straight guys in a fraternity
kind of gave me the confidence that they
don't think that I'm coming on to them
just because I'm gay so that kind of
helped me come more comfortable with my
sexuality when you get to the core of
who you are like people are gonna like
you or not like you for much more than
just your sexuality once I was a senior
and I was out and everything I had a
couple of them actually come up to me
like one on one and say like hey I'm
actually kind of dealing with like
coming to terms with my sexuality right
now and like how have you dealt with
coming out especially in a fraternity
that was kind of cool because I didn't
feel like I had that my fraternity
brothers are some of my best friends I
use up most of my vacation days spending
it with them they're the ones who bring
up political issues to me and are
outraged about it sometimes more than I
am about certain LGBT issues it gave me
a lot of life lessons it gave me really
good opportunities to to be a leader as
an undergrad you're like sort of
entering this life where you're fighting
trying to figure out who you are you
know where you fit in with a lot of
things and I think for a lot of you know
LGBT folks especially those who start
rushing opportunities it's a challenging
time and so I think being comfortable
about being gay is something that you
have to discover and figure out on your
own at the end the day I definitely you
know look out for yourself and protect
yourself and and there are probably some
organizations that are more accepting I
wouldn't have so many of the friends
that I have and I would have had some of
the experience that I had had I not join
a Greek organization and if I had let
fear of my sexuality stop me I would be
such a different person
[Music]
Wow